this is a purple tomato just kidding
it's your typical garden variety type
but the purple ones do exist tomatoes
that are purple all the way through
aren't available anywhere in the world
just yet that's because they're
genetically modified but they're on the
cusp of getting the approval from
regulators to end up on your plate and
the journey of this little tomato from a
lab in the uk to your salad bowl could
be a really big deal to start in lab
experiments cans of prone mice that were
fed purple tomato powder live 30 longer
but nutrition is only one part of the
story it's also about the shelf life of
the food we eat and its origins let's
dig in a gmo or genetically modified
organism is an organism whose genetic
material has been altered using genetic
engineering to include the genes of
another organism believe it or not this
could be the second genetically modified
tomato to hit shelves the flavor saver
tomato was sold in grocery stores in the
90s but at the end of the day it was
kind of a flop because it was expensive
to produce and market plus there was
public distrust and backlash against
gmos a distress that kind of persists to
this day are they safe
are they natural who knows
we'll get to that but first let's talk
about nutrition the purple gmo tomatoes
that could go on sale sometime soon are
purple all the way through because
they're loaded with antioxidants called
anthocyanins they're found in foods like
blueberries and blackberries and they
give those fruits their signature colors
nutrition experts in studies say that
these molecules are good for us because
they help ourselves fight off their
version of stress which helps them stay
healthy longer nearly 20 years ago kathy
martin who's a plant geneticist at the
john innes center in the uk set out to
make a tomato that was loaded with
anthocyanins we thought that this was a
cool way of doing something that was
quite attractive and a bit different to
try to make a better tomato she and her
team inserted two jeans from the
snapdragon into regular tomatoes those
jeans act like a switch to turn on the
production of anthocyanins in a study
from 2008 kathy and her team showed that
cancer-prone mice whose diet was
supplemented with purple tomato powder
live longer than those supplemented with
red tomato powder and if you think that
that's just a change in diet no drugs
just a change in diet that's pretty
phenomenal really other food science
experts i spoke to warned that the
effects we see in lab animals don't
always pan out in humans but everyone
seemed to agree that fruits and veggies
should be the foundation of a good diet
another benefit of these gmo purple
tomatoes is their longer shelf life
that's good because it could make them
more commercially viable and reduce food
waste they have double the shelf life so
this tomato has been sitting on the
bench for about about six weeks her
purple tomato doesn't wrinkle or go soft
as fast as a regular tomato plus it's
also less susceptible to gray mold but
there are two big questions around gmos
are they natural and are they safe at
first glance the natural question seems
to have a pretty obvious answer
no because gmos don't exist in nature
but my conversation with harry klee a
plant biologist at the university of
florida made me think that maybe it's
not quite that simple he told me that
many of the foods we eat today aren't
all natural either they're the product
of years of deliberate genetic tweaking
after world war ii the international
atomic energy agency used to routinely
take batches of seeds like wheat corn
and expose them to high levels of
radiation in order to induce mutations
the word mutation kind of makes us
cringe but mutations are actually a
foundational part of nature farmers and
the ag industry leverage mutations or
genetic changes to make their products
better for example the mass production
of seedless grapes and watermelons
didn't happen naturally they are the
product of years of research and
development to make them easier for us
to eat usually to land on a beneficial
mutation developers have to screen
thousands of genetic changes to find the
one they're looking for geneticists say
that gmos and genetic engineering are
just a high-tech faster and more precise
version of that process that brings us
to the question of safety could this
high-speed evolution actually make our
foods unsafe well that's where the
government comes in for a gmo food to
make it to market developers have to get
regulatory approval that involves giving
regulators data on its chemistry and
other characteristics kathy and her
collaborators have done that and they're
waiting to get clearance from regulators
to sell their tomato in the u.s if this
tomato gets approved it would be the
first genetically modified tomato to be
sold directly to consumers since the
1990s
to start the purple tomatoes will be
sold to home growers as seeds what do
they taste like they taste like tomatoes
i can't claim anything special it just
tastes like tomatoes
the researchers i spoke to said that
eating gmos really just boils down to
personal choice they do expect that in
the future more of our food will be
genetically altered through genetic
engineering and recently the fda cleared
the way for the consumption of
gene-edited cattle that are supposed to
be more resistant to extreme heat
gene-edited foods will not be labeled as
gmos because they don't contain genetic
material from another organism so they
don't fit the technical definition of
what a gmo is plus in january regulators
retired the gmo label which will be
replaced by bioengineered or derived
from bioengineering to be perfectly
honest with you i am kind of curious
about what a purple pasta tomato sauce
would taste like or
maybe some purple ketchup to go with my
fries would you try a gmo tomato let us
know in the comments and if you like
this video hit subscribe
thanks for watching i went